hi James that gaara mobile health care
it's wonderful being out here at Davos
everyone's talking about the economy but
I think what's been emerging more than
just the financial crisis is how the
economy is affecting people's health
care and as we all know you know health
care is a center of vapor one's daily
life and during this economic crisis
it's much more challenging people are
smiling down I've learned back to
creature comfort foods going to chip in
become diabetic or that I can rebind
their medications it's absolutely
terrible and I think that's where
companies like us now or are really
helping to drive this issue of helping
to provide a global platform for South
disease management wellness and
prevention and I just wanted to say to
everyone out there that the leaders here
are just phenomenal their own listening
they're very proactive now health care
is taking center stage and which point I
was a about inauguration in estates it's
coming to the forefront and that could
be seen in Davos